what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video a few days ago I
made my breakdown video for the second
trailer and during that breakdown I told
you that I would be making a separate
video on bran stark scenes so that's
what I want to do for you today the last
time we saw a brain in mirror was in the
season 6 finale when benjin dropped them
off at the weirwood tree that's not too
far from Castle black benjin told brand
that he couldn't take them through the
wall because of the magic woven into its
foundation and I always thought it was
interesting benjin told Brandes because
we know the night king and the others
cannot pass through the wall because of
that magic but as we all know bran Stark
was marked by the night King which then
allowed the night king to enter the
three-eyed Ravens cave and since the
children of the forest hope bran the
Builder with the wall you have to wonder
if it has the same magic that the cave
once had because if it is the same magic
then it's very possible that the mark on
brains arm may affect it at the wall as
well if that's the case then that means
when bran crosses through the wall then
it may allow the night king and his army
to now have access also this will be
something we're going to have to keep
our eye on throughout the season and
there is also a chance that the mark on
Brandon's arm may never be mentioned
again
but when season 7 begins we may see
Brandon Mira's still at the weirwood
tree outside of the wall bran may
download some more information before he
head south but they will get to the wall
at Castle black fairly early in this
season because we know this season will
be short and from the trailer we did
learn that Brandon does make it back to
Winterfell as well when Brandon Mara get
to Castle black they will most likely be
greeted by Lord Commander edie who is
one of John's closest friends at the
wall and will probably bring brand up to
speed on everything that has happened
with John but bran may already know
everything by the time we see him again
depending how long bran has been into
weirwood tree where benjin dropped him
off he may have already had flashbacks
of John's death and the Battle of the
bastards and everything else it's hard
to say how much more bran will have
learned by the time we see him again but
it will be interesting to see what bran
will tell the Nights Watch in my opinion
I think bran should warn them about the
mark on his arm he should let them know
that there is a possibility that the
night king may still be tracking him
down
and that the mark can potentially allow
the night king and his army access
through the law now
know that the Nights Watch will not
stand a chance against the night King
but they should at least be warned that
the magic in the wall may no longer work
once they let bran come south but after
a short time at the wall Brandon Mira
will eventually head home and once
mirror drops bran off at Winterfell she
will probably go back to her home as
well but I'm hoping when Mira goes home
she can get into contact with her father
so that he can come into play at some
point by the time bran arrives at
Winterfell Jon will most likely have
already left for Dragonstone but we will
at least get a small stark reunion with
bran and songs at first at least until
Arya can make it back home but there was
another quick scene in the trailer that
shows bran out in the godswood at the
weirwood tree and there is a maester
standing next to him I do believe this
is the Bolton's former maester he was on
set the same day brand Arya and songs
are on set too they will most likely all
be at Winterfell at the same time near
the end of the season brain is going to
be spending a lot of time out here at
the weirwood tree in fact there was
another scene in the trailer that shows
brand at this weirwood tree but it's
very easy to miss at the beginning of
the trailer it starts with the scene of
Sansa walking away from the godswood
and as sanjay is walking away if you
look right over her shoulders you can
see a glimpse of a figure right under
the tree in my opinion it looks like
brand sitting down in the wheelchair and
I think bran and Songza will have a
discussion out here about Littlefinger
brain is going to expose him to Sansa
and this is when she's going to decide
that he needs to be killed which causes
her to walk away like this knowing that
her mind is made up
Littlefinger must die as Sansa walks
away from the godswood we can also hear
a quote from Littlefinger at the same
time and this may be what Littlefinger
says the Sansa as his last words they've
gave us so many teases with Littlefinger
and all the promos and they have shown
him in nearly every single one either
down in the crypts or wasanta
it's great if a character Littlefinger
is this will be his last season once
bran gets home he will no longer be able
to play his manipulating game brain will
eventually learn of everything and he
will bring Songza out here to tell her
this will be a pretty big revelation
next season but it won't be the only one
when we see bran out here with the
maester you
see that he is either having a flashback
or he is working they also show us a
dozen of crows flying over thousands of
lights in the way they edited this it
appears that brain is working the birds
at this moment but if you know how they
edit these trailers they do it this way
to throw us off when they show the crows
flying over the white they also cut to a
quick scene of the night King looking up
into the sky I think they want us to
think he is looking up at the birds but
this could be two completely different
scenes which it most likely is but let's
take a closer look at some things and
see what else could possibly be going on
here now we know that Jon Snow and a
group of companions are going to go
north of the wall and we also know that
they are going to come into contact with
the night Kings army we can see Jon and
his men get attacked by a shitload of
whites here on this cliff and we also
see Jon fight a white Walker in one of
the last scenes it shows Jon standing
here alone with several white standing
in front of him back there near the fire
but if you look closely at the whites in
front of Jon there really aren't too
many standing there at this point and
considering there are some big fires
back there most of the whites that were
here in this attack are probably killed
so when we see the crows flying over
this big army of whites in the trailer I
think this is going to be a different
scene if you pause the video and look at
all the whites you can see that this is
most likely the entire army of whites
you can see them as far as the eye can
see
and they don't seem to be running or
scrambling in this scene either and I'm
not sure if I've ever mentioned this
before but I was actually in the Army
for four years and anyone that's been in
the military knows that you spend a hell
of a lot of time standing in formation
and marching in formation and when I
look closely at all these whites here it
looks like they are marching they are
not running none of their legs are bent
at the knee nor do they look to be
leaning forward at all in my opinion I
think this is the army of whites
marching to the wall at the end of the
season I think we will see the night
King round up his entire army and
finally make his move to come south also
when they showed the night king look up
into the sky here I think this could be
the night king looking up at the wall
and when the scene cuts back to bran we
see branch snap back out of his vision I
think this could be brand realizing like
oh [ __ ] the night king and his massive
army of why
sir at the [ __ ] wall and it's show
time brain is going to warg into his
birds and witness them mounting up to
strike the wall in the Nights Watch
we know that the night king took some
kind of interest in Jon Snow when he saw
Jon Snow kill one of his White Walkers
when Jon snow gets north again and he
comes into contact with the night king
again this is going to heighten
everything but Jon will be able to
escape the night Kings grasp once again
but this time it's going to piss the
night King off especially if Jon and his
team are able to escape was something
that belongs to the night king he
already marked bran and we know he has a
massive interest in bran - so after Jon
Snow returns from this mission the night
king will have nothing left to do up
north but to come south and bran knows
this marina is going to work into the
birds to go spy on the night king and
see what the hell he's up to but to
brain surprise he's going to realize the
night king and his army are making their
move south and when we see the night
king look up into the sky here this
might be the last scene of the season
this might be him looking at the wall
falling down how crazy would that be now
I know they want us to think he's
looking up at something flying in the
sky but it could also be something else
but what do you all think comment down
below and let me know am I crazy for
thinking this or does it make some sense
thanks for stopping by and checking out
this video I really appreciate the
support from all of you I love you all
and I'll see you down below bye